fait moins le malin de leurs noms mais
pourquoi pas jean nuit parce que c'est
mieux comme ça j'en savais qu'on peut
tous faire implanter pour ceux qui font
pas de sport par exemple autour de la
table alors lorsque tout à l'heure je
peux le dire oh là je me dis tu veux pas
faire de faux aveux faire du sport et
oui mais je n'aurai que j'ai proposé ne
veut pas bah oui mais ben tu ferais bien
mais sûrement
[Applaudissements]
voir il a vu que leur fournit tous là
franchement il a encore hyper correcte
ou non vraiment
je le devrais me sentir pour vous
messenger pour les spectateurs pourquoi
tu m'as vu torse nu parce que parce qu
on se change dans la même loge oui voilà
les sacs on n'a pas l'argent dit il avec
un sourire et bonne chose que là c'est
parce que ça crée des liens c'était le
but mais perd connaissance
[Applaudissements]
et on l'a vu à dire la vérité après
l'émission se change tout dans la loge
et m'a proposé de me laver au gant et
ses attraits l'émission si nous savons
ce qu'il se passe en loge mon dieu
donc allez donc j'ai des 120 dollars à
planter des pecs des amendements à des
biceps des tris et dont ils sont chez
vous maison mais ça sert à quoi parce
que si tu as tu peux rien porter parce
que t'as pas nue ça c'est sûr que c'est
un peu quatre de leurs mots ce qu'il
avait perdu contre un bras de fer
je les paie contrats 4g encore bombe
avec ses kenji et cyril et mokhtar au
bras de fer
[Applaudissements]
non c'est quand avec tout le respect que
j'ai pour cailly que j'embrasse et que
j'aime beaucoup c'est pas un état mais
en dehors de ça vous allez vous tapez
mokhtar déjà besoin docteur aller vers
un crime on accuse ben oui tu lui
proposes tu proposes pas d'aller faire
du sport fait moins le malin de leurs
noms mais pourquoi pas jean nuit mais
parce que c'est mieux comme ça un peu
jours lui qui attention
déjà la malle fait trois fois en quatre
mois ce gars à nono allez-vous go en
coulisses il a insulté
oui ensuite est amer
[Applaudissements]
m
selon les pompiers pour de l'hormone
on est venu prochain lors justement ces
petits balayage pour aller au bout de
l'information tu les as fait implanter
ou
[Applaudissements]
jean luc caraguel elle voulait faire un
petit bras direct de l'enfant sûr
qu'elle est capable de laisser aller
[Applaudissements]
suppl isabelle mon amour mais vraiment
des frac témoignent de leur mohammad s p
lui casser de bryan ont d'ailleurs dès
lors qu'elle manque d'élégance et a vu
des années des sommes qu'ils
vieillissent et qui se sont fait faire
des implants avec les plis qui repose
sur les âmes plein non ça vous regarde
voilà vous avez retiré mon âge on n'a
pas tout compris mais que ça très bien
parce que les appelants reste fixe comme
jean-marie baudoin l'a vraiment aller
ces galonnés mal pref gouv et allez-y
oui
il est méchant on va le retrouver dans
un instant le méchant très méchant de
l'armée
[Musique]